le festival de cannes avec le début de
la compétition officielle compétition
est un premier film français marie jo et
ses deux amours du marseillais robert
guédiguian le metteur en scène de marius
et jeannette à travailler une nouvelle
fois avec ses co média favori dans une
version plus aboutie de son cinéma
reportage sur la croisette dominique
poncet et olivier thiêt mer bleu azur
soleil radieux champagne pour ce jour de
début de compétition cannes a mis ses
habits de fête
et ça tombe bien c'est parfaitement
raccord avec les couleurs et le décor de
marie jo et ses deux amours
le film de robert guédiguian présenté
aujourd'hui sur la croisette
un film qui se passe à marseille sur le
bord de la méditerranée et qui raconte
l'histoire d'une femme partagée entre
deux hommes
une histoire de déchirements à la fois
simple forte et sincère
ce qui m'a touché quand j'ai lu le
scénario je me suis rappelé j'ai
travaillé au théâtre vente la mouette de
tchekhov ce que dit tchekhov sur la
matinée c
une tragédie avec des kilos d'amour
c'est ce que dit jacobs de sa pièce
quand j'ai lu ce trucage dit voilà c'est
ça c'est une tragédie avec des kilos
d'un mois j'arrive plumage on n'y arrive
pas j'ai plein de choses horribles dans
la tête quand pas aux rimes et des
salles penser ça me dégoûte je me
dégoûte moi même de penser à ça doit-on
lui arriver je trouve que ce film a il
est il est pétri d'humanité quoi il est
il transpire de du même coin qui nie pas
l'âge préféré qu'ils n'existent pas du
tout si j'ai lu ce thème n'est pas
tricard au générique de ce film on
retrouve les comédiens fétiches du
réalisateur marseillais
et ce n'est évidemment pas un hasard si
les gens apprécient ses filles mais si
les gens sont touchés par les échanges
qu'on a dans ses films c'est aussi parce
que les comédiens qui jouent dansent une
sont extrêmement liés mais c'est ça qui
est beau ce soir pour nous c'est qu'on
remonte tous ensemble les marches
anna paquin nié tous il y a vingt ans
que la tribu de robert guédiguian
attendait de savourer ce plaisir
ils sont radieux ils peuvent l'être même
sans obtenir la palme leur film devrait
connaître un beau succès populaire
et